The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we now have,
hopefully, I don't know.
I've been going to some of the
groups and we seem to be there
for at least one of the
groups I surveyed
by the end of yesterday.
We have a question.
We know what we'd like to
evaluate, and we have some
kind of a design.
So we know how we are going
to get a sample.
We know how we are going
to randomize.
And that's a good start.
So what we are going to do today
is getting to know that
we have a way of randomizing.
We're going to get into the
details of how we are actually
going to go about collecting the
data for the evaluation.
So it's not going to be so much
about the program, it's
going to be about thinking
how we really
want to do the survey.
Thinking about what is the
sample size we need, how many
data points we need, and what
data should we go about
collecting, and how much is it
going to cost, and what are
the trade-offs we are facing
when we are trying to address
those questions.
So we could be spending
from one week to one
year on these questions.
In particular, on the survey
design aspect.
These are complicated
questions.
Not many people who are much
more qualified, certainly,
than me on this issue
of how to ask the
right question correctly.
So we are not going to
get into any of that.
It's going to remain at a
somewhat abstract level of
business one.
It's going to be both abstract
and quite particular in a way.
At the abstract level is how
do we even think about the
type of data we want
to collect?
And at the concrete level it's
we're going to do it for one
particular example, which is
this Panchayat example which
happens to be one that
I know pretty well.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Not making
much progress, huh?
So what are the questions we
need to know the answer to
before getting ready to
start our evaluation?
One is what data should
we collect?
It's kind of a big question.
What should go in the
questionnaire?
Anybody among you who's
been involved in doing
questionnaires knows
that you cannot
ask a million questions.
And so how do we choose
what to put in?
And then, what systems we should
put in place to ensure
that the quality of
the data is good?
And what sample size
we need to plan.
So not going to do sample
size this morning.
It has its own little lecture
and a firm set of exercises.
So that's going to go
this afternoon.
We are going to be doing
a lot of that and
a bit of that today.
So let's start with the
Panchayat example.
So let's talk a bit
about the setting.
So the setting is a reservation
for women in the
Panchayat region in India.
So what's the Panchayat and
what's the reservation policy?
So the rule of the
game, I don't
ask rhetorical questions.
So when I ask a question,
someone needs to answer
otherwise we're stuck.
AUDIENCE: It was a program
designed to decentralize the
allocation of public resources
in villages
to the lower level.
And at the same time, you wanted
to ensure that meant
minorities and scheduled
tribes in India got
represented somehow, and the
preferences and opinions at
this Panchayat level.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the policy is Panchayat
stands to
consider five people.
And maybe in some historical
India there was this council
of five people who make
decisions for the villages.
Or maybe not, but anyway,
that's where
the name comes from.
And the idea, and that's not
only India, it's something
that you see in a lot of
developed and developing
countries today, is that
decisions regarding local
public goods such as drinking
water infrastructure, the
local wards, the buildings--
at least the buildings so, for
example, schools, health
facilities and such things--
would better represent people's
need if people had a
say in what they wanted.
So it's very difficult to know
if our bureaucrats sitting in
Delhi that such and such village
in the middle of Bihar
needs a road as opposed
to a water well.
And so you can get this
vast misallocation of
money in this way.
So the idea with the Panchayat
is that now even though the
revenue collection is still
pretty much not coming from
the villages where there is
not much taxation ability,
this one defending decision
should be taken increasingly
at this local level to ensure
that better adequation, a
better fit between what you
build and what people want.
The problem with that, of
course, is that when you have
local decision making it's
who is going to be
controlling the power.
So India, like many other
countries, perhaps even more
than other countries, has this
history of these conditions
again some particular group.
So, for example, the scheduled
caste who are the former
untouchable?
The scheduled tribe who don't
even have a caste?
And so the worries that there
are enough people, strong
people, in these groups, that at
the national level they can
organize to make sure that there
are policies that help
these particular groups.
Same thing for women.
There definitely are very
strong women in India.
But in any local villages, you
might not have a minority of
scheduled casual tribal women
who are able to take
responsibility to ensure that
their group is represented.
So they might never be
represented, you might have
some tyranny of the majority.
So that's why the system also
introduced this reservation
concept, which is to ensure
some representation.
So how does a reservation
work?
How did they put it in place?
AUDIENCE: They reserved a
certain number of seats for
women in each council.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there is one reservation at
the level of the council.
So we can say these are
various councils.
Each council has about, say,
10-12 representatives which
represent a population
of 10,000 to 12,000.
And so the first reservation
is within each council.
How many seats for women?
AUDIENCE: One third.
PROFESSOR: One third.
So each council gets one
third for women.
And what about SC and
ST What do they get?
STUDENT: In proportion
to their population?
PROFESSOR: In proportion
to their population.
Not in that particular
village, but
in the whole district.
So, for example, in Birbhum,
there is about, I think, 30%
of scheduled caste.
So every village needs to have
30% of scheduled caste, even
if they have much less.
Except that if they have less
than five, they're exempted.
If you have no scheduled tribe
in the village, you can not
have a scheduled tribe
representative.
So that's the first thing.
So are we going to be able to
evaluate the impact of having
this policy which has, within
each council, has one third of
the seats to a woman.
AUDIENCE: No, because
there's no control.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's going to be
very difficult
because there is no control.
So certainly we won't be able to
look at the impact of this
policy on what the council
does as a whole.
You might ask whether the
particular village where she
comes from, or segment of the
village where she comes from,
gets different good, possibly.
But certainly you're not going
to be able to compare the GPs
since they are different.
So what is the second layer of
the policy that's going to be
more helpful?
AUDIENCE: The Pradhan?
PROFESSOR: At the level
of the Pradhan.
And how does that work?
AUDIENCE: It's like
a rotation?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So how does it work for any
particular election?
AUDIENCE: It's like it gets
sorted or something?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what the deal exactly,
is that they rank them.
So these GPs have a serial
number, which is some number
that they had forever
and ever.
So they rank them by their
serial number and by
geographic unit.
So they first rank them by
block, and within each block
they rank them by their
serial number.
And then the constituent
three lists.
One list of what they call
general, one list of SC, and
one list of ST. So the general
list means it's not reserved
for an SC Pradhan.
Those SC lists means it's there
for a SC Pradhan, and ST
means it's there for
a ST Pradhan.
And the way I did this selection
is that they have to
stay with a random number which
they use to say, so if
you need to reserve it's
like a very long table.
Because it tells you if you need
to reserve five GPs, you
pick number 1, 15, 17,
and 21 for SC.
So they do this list this way.
And then this gives them three
lists, which are ordered by
serial number.
And in each list, they count
1-2-3, 1-2-3, 1-2-3, in the
first election.
All the GP number one
in all the lists got
reserved for women.
In the second election,
again this goes
through the same process.
And all the GP number two are
reserved, and the third
election, all the GP number
three were reserved.
So in principle there is a
rotation, though it is not
necessarily one for one in the
sense that if a GP happens to
be number one on this list in
the election in 2003, and
number two in this list
in 2008, they get
reserved twice in a row.
Possibly if they become number
three in this list, they would
do that three times in a row.
That could happen, too.
But twice in a row is pretty
frequent, actually.
So this is more hopeful because
now we have some GPs
that are reserved for women.
That says those three are
reserved for women.
And some who are not
in the same year.
So now we can compare them.
Compare the decisions that are
made in those places, compare
anything we would like to
compare, and we have a chance
to actually identify
the effects.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you compare if in
the non-reserve you elect a
woman, does that become part
of the control group, or?
PROFESSOR: So what's your
thinking on that?
So two things could
happen, right?
It could happen that in the
places that are reserved for
women, they elect a man
anyway in defiance?
So you don't have that
problem, actually.
They elected a woman.
And the other thing that could
happen is what you're talking
about, is that some of those
places might decide to elect a
woman anyway.
In fact, about 7% of them do.
So what do you think we
do with those guys?
AUDIENCE: They're part
of the control.
PROFESSOR: We keep them
in the control, right?
Because we're going to spend
more time on that tomorrow,
but if we did put them in the
treatment, then we don't have
a random selection anymore
because now in the treatment
we have the people who
are forced to have a
woman that's on them.
Plus the places that choose
that's not random.
So we'll be keeping them here,
and this is going to mean that
it's going to look a little
bit like an encouragement
design like you saw yesterday.
Which is, in the places that are
reserved for women, 100%
of them have women.
In the places that were
not reserved,
7% have women anyway.
So the difference is
not quite 100%.
So tomorrow we'll deal with,
see, so here we are going to
focus on the impact of being
reserved, and we're not going
to be concerned so much about
the impact of having a woman.
So we are still going to always
compare treatment
versus control.
Tomorrow you can see how, in
fact, we can do something
about thinking about how we go
from the impact of being
reserved, to the impact of
being a woman if we are
willing to make a couple
more assumptions.
So that's a better setting.
We can now compare those places
and even though the
Indian government didn't do this
beautiful experiment with
the view of an evaluation
in mind.
And they might have.
And then they might contact
you and say, hey, we
have this set up.
How should we go about
evaluating it?
And so that's the name
of the game.
So I think we went through
this maybe?
We can spend a little more
time on the goals.
So what do we expect from
the Panchayati raj?
What will give us a first sense
of what data we should
think about collecting to know
what's the goal of the
institution.
This big untraditional amendment
took place in 1993.
What was in the mind of the
policy makers at that time?
AUDIENCE: That there would be
more accountability to the
interest in priorities of
interested countries?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Greater women's
empowerment?
PROFESSOR: So I don't know if
it's a goal of the Panchayati
raj amendment per se, but we
could think it was something
people had in mind in the
reservation policies.
AUDIENCE: That program selection
would be more
aligned with the local
preferences?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Program selection might reflect
local preferences.
We should keep that in mind.
AUDIENCE: To increase
the quality and
quantity of public goods?
PROFESSOR: Right.
We can see that there is more
as a result of their
accountability, there might be
better and more public goods.
AUDIENCE: More participation
in public life?
PROFESSOR: Right.
We might also think that we
might value the participation
for its own good.
I would think it's a good thing
if people are involved
in local democracy.
AUDIENCE: They vote more?
PROFESSOR: They vote more,
participate in meetings,
things like that.
So that's kind of the sum of the
objective of the Panchayat
raj, generally.
And within that there was
this reservation.
And the reservation policy is,
was, still is in a sense,
quite controversial.
It is still controversial in the
sense that the next step
they are asking themselves now,
and in fact I think has
always been somewhat lurking in
the background, is should
there be reservations
at other levels.
For example, for
foreign peace.
Like, should there be
reservations in the parliament
modeled on the one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] model, but
akin to what we have
on the Panchayat.
And that debate is
lively in India,
but it's also elsewhere.
Many countries have reservation
policies.
Last I counted, hundreds of
some kind of some form of
mandated representation
for women.
So it is not a very prominent
policy, and some countries are
very opposed to that.
For example, the US.
So what are the potential
pros and cons of
a reservation policy?
Since our evaluation is meant
in a sense to inform this
debate, we should think about
what are the questions that
are in people's minds?
AUDIENCE: It's not democratic.
It's not majority rule.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's a disadvantage.
So it's not democratic, I'll
just put it that way.
We are constraining
people's choices.
They might not like it.
So that reduces their utility.
AUDIENCE: But there is this
structural inequality, so you
need to empower your
women [INAUDIBLE]
do it, [INAUDIBLE]
this reservation
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But at some point in history,
you need to do it to push
women farther.
PROFESSOR: So I see more than
one thing in that comment.
One is that in the short run
we need to ensure woman's
representation.
That's the short run.
And I think what I also hear
in your comment is that--
AUDIENCE: So many noises
in the room.
It's not working as it should.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one of the reasons why you
might want to ensure woman's
participation is
just because--
just like that.
Not even because you think it
will affect, again, like
democracy here is an
end in itself.
You might think, well, democracy
is not real because
women are not participating.
I'm interested in having women
participating, period.
Even if it doesn't change
anything to the outcome,
that's what makes
democracy real.
So that could be one outcome.
So we are interested in that
as an end in itself.
And I think one thing that I
overhear in your comment that
might not be there in reality,
is also that maybe that will
help jump-start the process
where that would not be needed
in the long run.
So it would ensure a woman's
representation in the long
run, and maybe change
voter's view.
View is such that in the long
run, the effect would persist.
In which case you might go to a
bigger and better democracy
where everybody's actually
involved.
In fact, it might be good
for men as well to avail
themselves of the possibility
of half the population's
talents which now, for some
reason, becomes shut.
So that's a first set of things
which concerns the
participation itself.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
advantages of ensuring women's
representation is that they
might then allocate more money
to goods or services that
benefit women's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that is certainly
something you hear a lot.
So we allocate more money to
goods and services which,
sorry, can you repeat the end?
AUDIENCE: Which benefit women
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Which
benefit women.
Which might be good if--
you were saying that woman
were not represented
adequately before, and all--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then there might
also, I mean, there's been
some literature saying that
there's been a spillover
effect for children and
families, but if [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's also something
you hear a lot which
is, so this is an argument in
favor of redistribution.
To half the population there
is a group that doesn't get
very much in the
normal system.
They need to get some part
of the rent as well.
And then that's sort of one
step further which is an
efficiency argument.
You say, as you do that,
you will also get a
different type of goods.
STUDENT: Increases a woman's
empowerment.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So as you do that you might
also increase a woman's
empowerment.
I think it's a double
positive, but I'll
leave it like that.
Empowerment.
Which may be good again as a
redistribution or because we
think that women in the house
will do things differently.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the same thing
as empowerment, but maybe more
measurable is that it claims
to reverse the trend of
increasing gender gap
in the population?
PROFESSOR: So one of the
possible outcomes would be
gender gap.
You mean among children
or among adults?
AUDIENCE: Eventually it will
be among the adults, but it
can be noticed [INAUDIBLE]
indicators would be like
reduction in girl infanticide.
PROFESSOR: So do we think there
is a direct rule between
what women policy makers can do,
in terms of what type of
public goods they can provide?
Or do you think it's going to be
all indirect to doing stuff
that benefits women, which
increases the power of women,
which means that they make
decisions that are better for
girls in the household?
AUDIENCE: And perception,
it will quickly
change in our society.
PROFESSOR: So there is an issue
of perception as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that when you see [INAUDIBLE]
it would be more
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to follow.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you might think that might
be something that people are
also talked about is just,
again, not just the aspect of
what she might be doing.
Just having the woman as the
figurehead changes the image
in a somewhat more
permanent way.
You don't just think well, she's
there because of the
reservation.
You see a woman in a position of
power and that might change
your view of what's possible.
AUDIENCE: As a disadvantage, you
also have the potential of
the women who have poor job and
so the perception actually
becomes negative, if it's
perceived that the woman might
be unqualified.
PROFESSOR: So the first woman
might be unqualified, and that
would worsen perception.
And then the other thing that
your comment could be read as
is maybe they're not
particularly unqualified, but
they are perceived as
being unqualified.
Because they are perceived as
being there because of the
reservation policy.
And, in fact, it's makes it
even more difficult for
competent women to assert
themselves.
That's something that has been
said a lot about affirmative
action in the US.
For blacks, for example, now
every time you see a black
person succeeding you're
thinking, why?
It's because they got some
unfair advantage somewhere,
and so that makes
things worse.
AUDIENCE: Backlash.
PROFESSOR: So we can write
it as backlash.
That's a very good point.
So that's a question that
we can also ask.
What's the perception of women,
and women in power
before and after?
AUDIENCE: We also create
this backlash.
It's my perception of it, too,
but it's a different issue.
It's not necessarily clear
that women will, in fact,
represent women better.
It is possible that women will
feel the need to compensate
and therefore go out of their
way to identify with men's
issues, and go out of their way
to not be perceived as a
feminine candidate.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I'm looking for a term for
that but I don't find one.
Women may overcompensate
and not
represent women's interests.
AUDIENCE: As an advantage having
women on the councils
that you bring more information
that may benefit
women but also may just benefit
the entire society.
Because you weren't getting this
channel of information
either directly from their
communities, or from their
constituents who don't feel
comfortable with women
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
You may be more information.
For example, because women speak
up more, and so they
give their opinion on stuff and
there is stuff they might
just know better about, even
if they don't particularly
care more about.
Everybody may have the same
preferences so that might not
be a conflict.
If you never hear from the women
that the water well is
blocked, then you may never
think of fixing it even though
that's something that would
benefit everybody ultimately.
AUDIENCE: An advantage would be
building capacity in women
for leadership for the
higher levels.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we are now talking about
spillover over time.
That you have one woman one
time, and people understand
that they are good and then
they can continue on.
But it can also be, of course,
different levels while you're
building up a cadre
of powerful women.
AUDIENCE: I would think that you
could maybe get an income
of that, right away, on women.
We vote next year to put
in a water well.
That means that there's a lot
more time to do my trading
business, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
business, so that right away I
might make more money.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one of the ways we can put it
into women empowerment, I'm
going to add "to," so it
could be to income.
It could be to time that you
generate, because now you
spend less time collecting
water.
Or it could be to the role
models as already discussed.
But just the fact that I have
the public good that is
convenient for me,
that I need.
And presumably if women's power
increased, they're going
to do some kind of public good
that's good for them which
might be these types of things
that will free times for them.
AUDIENCE: Kind of a counterpoint
to the last
disadvantage.
It's also possible that because
a woman doesn't have
to compete against a man, they
don't have to pander to men,
and in a sense, overcompensate
to men's preferences as much.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in a reservation--
we have too many advantages.
AUDIENCE: You add to
disadvantage also which is
that, I think, this may be more
indirect in the sense
that when you're electing
someone on the premise that
they'll able to deliver public
goods to a specific
constituency, you risk perhaps
instituting a culture of
paternalistic government that is
elected just to deliver the
pork to a specific
constituency.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And that is something that
has been discussed a lot.
For example, with the scheduled
caste is that you
could have this shifting.
So you go it's your turn, it's
our turn, it's your turn, it's
our turn, and then people are
not really watching the
scheduled caste guy because they
understand this is the
scheduled caste guy's
time to take their
turn, and vice versa.
It might also go the other
way in the sense that the
scheduled caste people
who were previously
disenfranchised might now feel,
well, we might as well
get this guy to deliver really
well while he is
in power for us.
Same thing for women.
But the effect on
accountability
is it's a good point.
Because since the whole
Panchayat is about
accountability to the people,
the effect of reservation
system on accountability,
at best, ambiguous.
So we can say this is related
to this first point which is
it's not democratic anymore.
So any tampering with the
democracy you might have story
going either way.
But that's a disadvantage
showing, effect on
accountability.
You're now accountable
to nobody.
First, you are a lame duck.
There is a very poor chance that
you get reelected again,
so that's your point here.
Which in a sense makes you free
to pander to your guys
which is maybe what we wanted in
this case, but on the other
hand, makes you maybe less
likely to deliver.
Sorry, there was a--
AUDIENCE: Another potential
disadvantage which is kind of
still under whether or
not women are in fact
representing, is that if there's
a culture of women not
speaking up or not advocating,
then you might end up with no
representation at all.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there is a question
of who is in charge.
So it might be that when it's an
election you elect someone,
they're in charge.
Here it's like maybe no woman
really wants to run, so you
pick up any figurehead.
It might go back to
elite control.
If nobody who's democratically
elected is in a position to
exercise the power, whoever
is a natural leader
will take it back.
It might be her husband, it
might be anybody else.
It's a very pretty reasonably
recent effort that local
democracy at that level.
And it might be crazy to go
back to elite control.
So who is in charge?
And is there a risk
of elite control?
Which is of course not why we
did this in the first place.
AUDIENCE: I guess it builds
upon the last point maybe
overall less efficiency in elite
administration functions
because there may be resentment
against the women,
so less cooperation
against them.
So maybe there's more stalemate
policies being passed.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's a risk of stalemate.
So unless you have a burning
point, then we stop here
because I have no space
anymore on the board.
So that's it, that's budget
constraint for thoughts.
So there is kind of a lot of
ideas and so somehow we are
going to want them organized
in order to go
and collect our data.
So one thing we could think
of doing is that, oh let's
postpone the big
deorganization of the thoughts.
We can see that it can go all
over the place, so let's go
and collect a bunch of outcomes
and see how it goes.
So given all of what we have
discussed here, what are the
possible things that might be
affected by this policy?
I'd like to have a board.
I can just write.
Given all the discussion we had,
what are the things that
we think might be affected
by having
this reservation policy?
A lot of these things already
came in, but we can make a
little list for ourselves.
AUDIENCE: Choice of which
public goods--
PROFESSOR: So one is definitely
the public goods.
So the disadvantage
I'm going to--
so outcomes--
oh, wow.
I don't usually use boards,
so I'm going to--
ta da.
That has to be MIT.
So we have a whole
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], so one is
clearly public good,
and potentially we
have lots of them.
What are the public goods that
we can see in villages?
AUDIENCE: Water.
PROFESSOR: Water.
AUDIENCE: Roads.
PROFESSOR: Roads.
AUDIENCE: Schools.
PROFESSOR: Schools.
AUDIENCE: Hospitals.
AUDIENCE: Health centers.
PROFESSOR: Small health
centers, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Young centers.
PROFESSOR: Young centers.
AUDIENCE: Large buildings.
PROFESSOR: Large buildings,
irrigation, biogas.
AUDIENCE: Electricity.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Electricity,
potentially.
Sanitation.
So like a long list of public
goods could go either a way,
so that's a long list.
Where else?
AUDIENCE: Perceptions
about women.
PROFESSOR: Perception
of women.
So if you want we'll talk a bit
more about how we measure
perception about women.
AUDIENCE: Participation.
PROFESSOR: Political
participation.
So attendance at meetings,
voting.
And of course we have
men and women.
That might be different.
AUDIENCE: Better governance?
PROFESSOR: So that's kind
of the same thing.
So better governance.
In practice that's going to be
whether there is graft, maybe
budget utilization.
So some measure of corruption.
Bribes.
You didn't say it actually
in the advantages or
disadvantages.
The women are less corrupt,
more corrupt.
I guess it came up in
the accountability.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Household income.
PROFESSOR: Household income.
And while we are in
the household?
AUDIENCE: Health education.
PROFESSOR: Health education.
Any gender differences in these
things, both for the
household and for the kids.
We were talking about gender
discrimination within the household.
So again it's like a long
list of household stuff
potentially.
Was a woman participating
in savings,
groups, blah, blah, blah?
There is both perception of
women politicians, and we also
discussed about perception
of women in general.
What else could we need?
AUDIENCE: Maybe greater
employability of women?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's going to be maybe an
income and then employment.
That's part of the long
list of stuff we might
collect in a household.
AUDIENCE: Social cohesion.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's maybe political
participation and social cohesion.
Don't know how you measure
that, but we can
think about it later.
AUDIENCE: Sustainability.
Or sort of decentralization
of power.
The majority that's been in the
government, it's like a
vicious cycle.
They'll do everything to keep
the minorities out of the
governance, so if you had jump
started this process by
introducing 30% of women--
PROFESSOR: Right,
right, right.
So it's perception of women
politicians is in a woman's
future electoral success.
Is it the case that once a place
is reserved for a woman,
obviously you are the woman.
How about the next time when
it's not reserved anymore, do
you have more woman
candidates?
Do you have a woman elected?
Women's future electoral
successes.
That's one of the first things
we had discussed.
More?
I think it's a pretty
long list already.
And so now that we have this
long list, the issue
is what do we do?
Suppose you had no
money problem.
Suppose budget was
not a problem.
Would you just take
this long list?
So one possible thing is to say,
well, we'll think about
this thing later.
That makes a long list
of outcomes, and
go and collect data.
So we're going to do a household
survey and a
community survey, and then an
audit of what's there in the
villages, and we are going to
collect a bunch of data.
And then this data will
come back, and we'll
start to look at it.
So what are the pluses and
minuses of that approach?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
statistical significance.
If you collect so much data,
eventually you'll randomly
stumble upon a result, and maybe
that's the result that
you end up reporting.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in particular, since we have
seen at least some of the
groups starting to discuss
power, so you've seen
hypothesis testing.
So if I ran a hundred regression
and looked for
significant results and then
independently looked for
results in each of them, how
many of them would count
significant at the 5% level?
AUDIENCE: Five.
PROFESSOR: Five.
So if I run 20, I
would get two.
So by example, suppose I collect
20 public goods, which
is not such a large number.
And we find that water wells
go up in places which have
more women, and irrigation goes
down, and anything else
doesn't change.
What can I conclude if I have
just gone on to this big
fishing expedition?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, you don't know
whether it was just random.
You can definitely
make up a story.
What is a story you could easily
make up on the basis of
those results?
AUDIENCE: That women invest in
wells because collecting water
used to be a woman's job, and
men invest in irrigation
because farming is a
man's occupation.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So you could say, well, women
are not going to benefit from
irrigation anyway, they're going
to benefit from drinking
water a lot.
So this is quite consistent with
what we were saying about
women leaders investing in the
goods women want, and so
that's great.
The only problem is, if we've
done that ex-post, someone
else could say, well, or an
alternative interpretation is
you've run 20 regression, you've
found two significant,
and you're making up
a story ex-post
to explain the results.
It's not that it's morally
wrong to do that, but if
you're not sure it is always
going to be some suspicion.
And then it's a little bit sad
to have spent so much money
collecting so much data and
not to be very sure how to
interpret the results.
So maybe that's not the
right approach.
Maybe we need to do something
slightly different, and that
is we need to try and put a
little bit more thought into
why we are collecting each piece
of data and where it's
going to fit in our global
explanation of the results.
So if you take this specific
example, instead of doing what
we just suppose we did, which
is making this long list of
results and hope for the best.
Instead, if we had said we are
going to go after this one
question, potentially we can
have we can have more than one
big question.
But we are at least going to
go after this one question
which is, what is it the case
that the women leader do what
women want?
And we had given ourselves the
means to first find out what
women want for real, and not
making it up from the results.
The key is to try to not be in
a position where you're going
to have to reverse engineer
your explanation
of the result ex-post.
If you want me to be completely
honest, it's very
difficult not to do that.
Because once you see the results
you always want to
explain them to yourself,
and explain to others.
So I'm not about to tell you
that from a position of where
I sit and say well, don't you do
that or you will be damned
and go to hell.
But the truth is that we do it,
but the truth is the less
we have to do it the better.
And you have to do it less if
you've been thinking ex-ante
about what it is that you want
to test, and what are the
steps that align themselves
in order to get to
where you want to be.
And this result might have been
totally fine if we had a
good way to say this is what
woman are really interested
in, and we had collected
data on that.
And then where our test will not
be good by good, is it the
case that women do
different things.
But we ask the questions
that generally do
women go in that direction.
And what is the case?
Yes, we're missing a moral
explaining to us why it is.
How do we go from this
hypothesis we have that women
are going to do what women want,
to how is it going to
translate into the
public goods.
So the hypothesis to test must
be defined before the
beginning of the experiment or
we don't know how to assist
their validity.
And what we missed when we did
this big list of outcomes, or
what we would have missed if we
just did this big list of
outcomes, and then go out and
collect the data and then
think about how to interpret
them, is these steps.
Which is go from a discussion
which is very likely at an
implicit level at the
back of our minds.
In fact, now it's very much in
the front of our minds since
we just had it.
But usually when you do an
evaluation, it's everybody
sort of had that in mind, but
it might remain implicit and
it's much better to
make it explicit.
First because you're more likely
to collect the data
that you actually will need.
For example, here we might have
missed collecting women's
preferences.
It's not in the list.
It's not in the list of
data that's here.
Why?
Because it's not an outcome.
So if were just thinking
about, oh, what are the
effects, and we forget to
collect women's preferences.
But then we have no good way to
interpret the preferences
in the context of that model
if it was the model.
So if we don't do this thinking
implicitly, we might
be missing a key step.
In particular, in what we call
the intermediate variable that
might be needed not as a measure
of the impact of the
program, but as what is going
to help us interpret the
impact of this program.
So you need to try and define
the hypotheses before the
beginning of the experiment.
And this is actually an exercise
that's very useful in
my experience working with
implementation partners.
It's very useful
for both sides.
Because from the side of the
evaluation team, strive to
understand what is the program
you're evaluating.
How it connects to what you know
about, say, developments,
poverty, et cetera.
From the side of the partner,
many of you have more
experience than me on that.
At least the half that are
actually into implementation.
It's like why are
we doing this?
Sometimes the answer is not as
forthcoming as you might hope.
AUDIENCE: The other thing that
was noticeable to me when we
were doing this is that there
are different levels maybe of
importance, or that
a lot of them are
subsets of other things.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So one of the things that you
might do in this process is to
prioritize what is sort of the
big news, sort of the million
dollar question?
What are subsidiary?
What are things that are
going to enlighten
whatever impacts you find?
So you might also, we are going
to do that in a minute,
is to think depending on how
much money you have--
is it that good?
So sorry.
We are trying to do something.
Given how much money you have,
you might be thinking of some
small things, or some
things that might--
for example, some of the things,
like say, one of the
outcomes we are thinking is
relative mortality of girls.
You might think realistically
two years after the women's
empowerment is less
likely to happen.
So if you had an infinite amount
of money, you might
still collect it as a subsidiary
outcome, but you
wouldn't want it in a long list
up there with whether or
not they invest in
water wells.
There's no way to do this
prioritization unless you are
in good cause the exercise of
thinking to your causal model,
linking whatever intervention
you have to the results.
AUDIENCE: In this discussion I
believe you also raised the
possibly of doing like a factor
analysis to create an
index of different factors so
that we could reduce the
number of variables.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's a very good idea.
But on the other hand, you have
to think about how to--
your instinct is the right one,
which is to say how are
we going to combine
this stuff?
So if you take, for example,
the 20 public goods.
If you're like, but these women
are more efficient,
they're going to build
more goods.
Then you might want to do that,
or you might want to sum
them or to average them somehow,
which is what making
an index is.
To see whether in general
all go positive.
But if your model is along this
line which is women are
doing what women want, then you
might not get more goods.
You may get some of some, and
less of others, so you might
need something else than an
index to deal with this mess.
But you're exactly right with
the idea that what we want is
a way to not have many, many,
many hypothesis, but fewer.
So, for example, it can be one,
which is a woman does
what women want.
That would be the first
one, and then what
comes out of that.
If that's your hypothesis, the
index you create would be
something different than
what you would get
from a factor analysis.
If, on the other hand, it's an
education intervention, and
you have a math result, and an
English result, and science
result, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
results, and geographic
results, then you know that
they should all up.
Or at least that's your
hypothesis they should all go
up, then you can do something
like that to average the
effect across the outcomes.
AUDIENCE: I understand why you
don't want to throw in 20
different outcomes.
But in terms of how you
prioritize the outcomes along
with their causal model, there
are some fields where it's
going to be fairly clear.
You know, in the health field,
they would say, OK, well, our
objective is to reduce
malaria, so we
didn't reduce malaria.
But if something that has more
intermediate steps along the
way, such as a--
PROFESSOR: What was
that about?
AUDIENCE: --such as like a
conflict mitigation program,
where you're saying, OK, we are
going to get children into
clubs because we believe that
this is going to create more
solidarity among ethnic groups,
and that this is going
to lead to conflict reduction.
When you have, like, six or
seven different steps along
this causal model, how and at
what point do you prioritize,
this is the impact that we're
looking for, versus these are
the steps that we have take
to get to this impact?
PROFESSOR: So that's a great
question, and you can answer
it at two levels in a way.
One is, where and when you're
going to see an impact first.
For example, in this case, you
might think that ultimately
what we care is not the
number of water wells.
Ultimately what we care is the
growth of the Indian economy
through these complicated
channels.
But this is not what we are
trying to do, because we think
it's going to take a
bit more time to
arrive to this question.
Or ultimately what we care about
is girl's mortality.
And we're thinking that through
this complicated path
we're going to get there
eventually, but this is not
the yardstick by which you
measure the success of the
program because it's in too long
time, and after too many
other things have
diluted this.
But at least you want to know
that you're going in the right
direction, so you might decide
to stop by the water wells for
the beginning.
Likewise in your program, you
might say you're going to
produce into groups
to work together.
You might say, well our first
measure of success with this
program is whether or not the
use opinion of the other guys
has changed in a way that
we can reliably measure.
And then you're going to ask
yourself the question of the
measurement, and then you can
take it at various steps.
And one is, am I still going
to find an effect after all
the things that have happened?
So is it fair to my program?
And the other is what
can I measure?
Some things are easier and
harder to measure, and they
might be at different
levels in the chain.
It might be that what is
happening first is easier to
measure, sometimes it's what's
happening a little later
that's easier to measure.
For example, perceptions might
be very hard to measure.
But whether or not people are
willing to work together to
build something might be very
easy to measure, so you might
go for that.
AUDIENCE: And at the same time,
you do want to make sure
that you're doing something
further enough along the chain
that there isn't actually
impact, and not just an output
measure, or--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So this is where this
conversation's going to be helpful.
What is our program hoping
to do, and how.
And sometimes you realize in
that conversation is that what
is your program hoping to do
so squishy that maybe we
should do something else.
But not the case of your
program that you just
described which sounded actually
quite specific in
what it was hoping to achieve.
So here's our example.
So we have to define
the hypothesis.
So, for example, we can take
here, we could take several.
One possibility is to take this
one which is public goods
favored by women are more likely
to be chosen by women.
So to test that, we need to know
what women want, and then
we need to collect the
data on public goods.
And then the one thing we are
going to do is, we are
creating this index of wanted
by women more than by men,
which is the way we
would aggregate.
And then the key test would be
are the public goods moving
towards what women want?
And so the one little snag is
how are we going to measure
women's preferences?
What is it that women want?
So what do you guys think?
What would be possibilities to
measure a woman's preferences?
AUDIENCE: Household surveys?
PROFESSOR: So we could ask them,
in household surveys.
That would be one way.
What they care about.
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: If there were
communities where women were
well represented, what were
the choices of those
communities, historically?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's slightly
circular because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that have a majority of women
on the local council have
higher percentage of wells.
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
That's a little bit circular,
because that means that what
we can do that only, A, if we
believe that, in fact, it is
true that women better do what
women want, which is what we
are trying to test.
And B, if we think there was no
selection in which village
elected a woman, and we don't
believe that which is the
whole reason why we
are going through
this tortuous exercise.
So that might--
AUDIENCE: I know in the exercise
it talked about the
transcripts from some of the
meetings, so you could look to
see if there were patterns for
what issues were raised.
Whether or not the council voted
on them, it was what
they brought to the table.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you could do that.
In fact, this is what
we did in this case.
Cheaper than household survey,
is to say, in general, what do
women ask about in
those meetings?
Preferably, not in places where
the woman is the head,
because that might have changed
the dynamic, but in
places which are not reserved.
What are women talking about?
What are men talking about?
And the advantage of a household
survey is that it's
a little bit costly to go and
talk about something.
In a meeting, you speak up and
other people look at you.
If you have to go to the leader
and have a written
complaint it takes some time,
and people wouldn't do that
unless they cared about it.
So maybe that's one
way to proceed.
But household surveys is also
a good way to proceed.
AUDIENCE: But if you're
measuring whether women
represent women, like you've
assumed at that point, but if
you're looking at the discussion
within the council,
you've assumed at that
point that the
woman that was selected--
PROFESSOR: Alright.
AUDIENCE: --for women.
So I was thinking of not the
small council, but the big
council when they have
this big meeting.
What she was referring to
is the transcript of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] meetings.
Or even when women have gone to
the office of the Pradhan
and asked them.
So that's different ways,
but the key is, we
need to have that.
Because then we can
see it doesn't
go into that direction.
And now we don't have 20 public
goods, we have one
hypothesis.
AUDIENCE: Is it necessarily
critical that what women are
speaking about when they go
visit to large meetings that's
what they want, and what the men
are speaking about, that's
what they want?
What if a man is speaking
on behalf
of his wife's interests?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it is not entirely clear.
And so this measure of women's
and men's preference might not
be the best you can think of.
The key is to have a good one.
I think you're right, which is
it could be that women never
speak for example, or never
complain about anything, and
they would still have
preferences so what would have
to figure something
out to get them.
To the extent that both genders
speak, then you might
think that they speaking about
what they care about as long
as the house is not a fully
harmonious unit.
Or you might think that it's
not, and then for example,
women tend to talk about water
just because they know better
about water as someone
suggested earlier.
And it doesn't represent needs,
it just represents
relative advantages.
So that is something that this
particular wealth measuring
preferences might not be
the best one, but the
key is to have one.
More than one would
be even better.
So in this case, that's the only
when we had so it was a
bit of a gamble.
But the key thing is that
we want to do that.
Then there are other things
we might be interested in.
So once we have that, do women
invest more in public goods,
then we can ask the next
question which is do investing
more once we find this that
kind of can be our study
number one.
Which is yes, we are showing
that women invest more in the
public goods that
women prefer.
Then there was this other
question that also came about,
a completely different question,
which is, does
having a woman as a policy maker
change the perception of
women as policy makers.
And that we can think of a
separate hypothesis altogether
that can be tested separately.
And it could be that women as
leaders do different things
and do what women want, but
that there is no lingering
effect of having a woman because
that doesn't affect
people's preferences or because
there is a backlash.
So we can think of these
two as different bins.
We can even do one
study and not the
other, of both of them.
But they are kind of separate
tracks to which to go.
So if we take a minute on
people's perception, do women
affect the perception of voters
of women leaders?
How would you go about
thinking about this?
How would you go about trying to
measure people's political
preferences?
AUDIENCE: Asking questions about
the role of women in the
household, or women
in the community.
PROFESSOR: So you can
ask questions.
So what is an issue
is this asking
questions in this context?
Do you like women leaders?
What do you think of--
AUDIENCE: People might feel like
there's a right answer.
PROFESSOR: People may feel
there is a right answer.
And what's the right answer, do
you think, in this context?
AUDIENCE: I see that you can
tell the story right away that
it's important to believe in
equality between genders.
Or that if you're a male, in
front of your other male
friends you want to appear
like a tough guy.
AUDIENCE: Or who's asking
the questions.
PROFESSOR: Or who is asking
Or you might think that it's
the right time to send a
message to say those people
from the capital who are
imposing this woman on us,
better tell them that really
we don't like it.
So it could really go either
way, we don't know.
And in a sense that is something
that is interesting
as well, is to ask which way is
what people are willing to
reveal to you?
In which direction is it best?
So then we would need some
measure of "to" preferences.
To willingness to consider
women as policymakers.
AUDIENCE: Their voting
preferences in the next cycle?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it seems that the litmus
test here would be voting.
Which is after one cycle of
reservation, or two cycles of
reservation, are women more
likely to be elected.
And that seems to be that it
would be like the place easier
to start or at least to end,
which is does it make a
difference?
And along the way, if you find
that you can think, well,
maybe this is because
of various things.
Maybe this is women started
to develop their networks.
Maybe women figured out that
they could do this.
So if we wanted to know that
it's really true, the change
in the perception of women as
policy makers, you would try
and get a measure
of perception.
Again, more to eliminate the end
line result, and to try to
get the measure of pure,
just one sort of--
AUDIENCE: Could you also--
so there are women elected
to these councils.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you also though
measure the women's
ascendancy to other kinds of
more management posts, like at
school level, or at community
groups or something like that,
as stepping stones on
the way to that?
PROFESSOR: Right.
That goes into this margin
on women's participation.
So you're thinking
[STUDENT NAME]
earlier was thinking up, like
do we see more women--
AUDIENCE: At higher levels.
PROFESSOR: --going
at higher level.
Or you could say do we see
more women in position of
power within the village.
AUDIENCE: Sink or swim.
PROFESSOR: School headmasters,
things like that.
School council, other
Going back to the perception
question, do you have an idea
of how we could go about
measuring people's perception
of women as policymakers?
AUDIENCE: We could have an index
of the satisfaction they
have with investments that women
have made, and try to
relate it to how much they like
or dislike the woman who
decided about this investment?
PROFESSOR: So we could try
satisfaction of the goods.
Thinking that in particular if
we had an objective quality of
the goods, we could say that if
their satisfaction of the
goods is lower even though the
goods are the same, it
indicates that they
like women less.
But that requires having a
very good measure of the
quality of the goods.
Otherwise, someone could always
say they are worse in
some dimension that you
didn't observe.
AUDIENCE: We could do some kind
of hypothetical question
that involves psychology,
or you're trying to--
PROFESSOR: So yeah, great.
Continue in this direction.
AUDIENCE: Where you're
interviewing people or doing
surveys, and you asked them to
imagine a scenario where you
have two different candidates,
and you give them the
backgrounds and one's a man and
one is a woman, and ask
them who they would pick.
I mean, that would be a poorly
disguised question--
PROFESSOR: If you have the two
candidates and you ask them to
compare, you might get
into the same issue.
But just go one step further
with this same idea.
You're almost there.
Or at least that's one
way of doing it.
AUDIENCE: You could present two
hypothetical CVs to people
and say, would like to
vote for this person.
But on one of the hypothetical
CVs, make it up as a woman,
and the other make it up as a
man, but they have all the
same qualifications.
And just see if there's a sense
that people would vote
more for one versus the other.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
You are [? interpreting ?]
values to different people.
Nothing forces you to present
the same questionnaire to
every person.
You could randomize within your
questionnaire what you're
going to show them.
So you're going to show them,
for example, exactly the same
CV and ask them, are you going
to vote for this person?
Or you could present a scenario
saying, so this and
this happened, and there was a
choice to be made, and they
decided to do this and
what do you think?
Was it a good decision?
And in one case it's like Mr. So
and So decided to do this,
and in one case Mrs. So and
So decided to do this.
If you ask both, you're
exactly right,
it was poorly disguised.
But if you ask only one, people
will answer the question.
And they don't have enough
information to really judge
the person fully.
Especially if you give them a
small scenario and then ask
them, will you vote for them?
So then we would bring in,
presumably, whatever else
their other views
on the person.
So then you will have compare
across surveys whether people
tend to rank more highly the
survey that has Mr. So and So,
versus the survey that
has Mrs. So and So.
The way we did it in the follow
up study to the one
that is in the case is we
actually taped speeches.
So we had speeches that someone
had given, and we had
a bunch of women record
the same speech.
And we then played a tape and
said, so what do you think?
So the advantage is, we don't
even have to insist on that
it's Mr. So and So, it's
just would you
listen to this speech.
And the voice immediately tells
you and then you can
compare people's answers.
And so now it becomes you have
to compare people's answers to
this question in the villages
that were reserved and the
villages that were not reserved,
and see whether any
gap changes.
An interesting fact is that then
you can correlate that to
what they actual tell you and
see whether, for example, it
might be that the real gap
doesn't change, but what they
tell you narrows, or it
could be the opposite.
If they're trying to signal
their dislike of the policy or
something like that.
And at the end of the day, all
of this leads to sort of I'll
find a hypothesis of did
this work, in a sense.
Which would be what are
the vote shares
for women in politics?
Or if you were less ambitious,
something like what are the
share of women who are
represented in positions of
power within the village as
you suggested earlier.
So that's something for day
two because we were on
measurement of outcomes.
I just wanted to give you one
example so we don't lack of
various ways we can
collect outcomes.
That's one way.
Going back to the example of
do women leaders better
represent the preferences
of women.
So what we try and do with an
evaluation is to try to find
out whether the program's just,
whether the program is
effective, but also why it's
really more helpful?
Both because well, we have a
richer understanding, and
because it will enrich our
understanding of the program
and also make it easier to draw
more general lessons.
Because for example, this
program you evaluate in West
Bengal and someone
can say, well we
need to work in Rajasthan.
So one way is to go and
do it in Rajasthan.
But then you can say,
well, but it worked
in Rajasthan, too.
We need to work in South India
and it cannot replicate
everywhere, everywhere.
So eventually you want to have
the ability to say something.
It's not necessarily we'll go
with some hypothesis, but to
say something that what is your
take at the end of the
day of the reasons why this
program will have such and
such effect.
So if you say, well what I think
is what's happening is
when women are elected, when
there is a reservation for
women they are doing stuff
that women prefer.
Then you can say, well, in West
Bengal what they want is
water so that's what
they'll do.
In, say, Tamil Nadu our water's
not so important--
well, it is very important to
me-- so in any place where
it's not so much of an issue,
I guess that wouldn't be
India, then they'll do that.
So as long as you tell me what
women care about, I can tell
you that it's going to
go in this direction.
It has the advantage that it
makes the replication more
interesting because if you're
doing North Bengal and then
you say, well now some goods
go up, some goods go down.
And then say you replicate in
Rajasthan a new level of tests
that you are willing to
subject yourself to.
If some goods go up, some goods
go down, it's like well,
maybe you don't even need to
do the evaluation because
probably you'll find it.
Whereas after the West Bengal
study you say, whatever I find
from this however imperfect way
to collect preferences is
what women prefer, this is the
same direction it's going to
move in Rajasthan.
So, in fact, in here
in this case it's
exactly what happened.
Because we first did West
Bengal, and we find that women
preferred water, according to
the measure of preferences,
and goods went to water.
And men prefer schools, which
was surprising to us and
others, but that's the
way it is, and the
goods went to schools.
So now for Rajasthan, we say,
well we are going to do the
same thing.
Find out what women want, what
men want in the same way.
It's going to go in
this direction.
And we find that there in
Rajasthan, also women prefer
water, but men love roads.
So we should have less roads.
More water, less roads.
While in West Bengal, women also
likes the road, for the
reason that they work on them.
They are the people who do the
roads, so it's employment
activities for them.
So it's interesting because we
have different predictions.
Our prediction is that the road
will go up in West Bengal
where you have women
reservation, and they will go
down in Rajasthan.
We know why, because it's
related to the thing.
And in fact we can make this
leap of faith beforehand.
And so that makes it much more
powerful once you replicate,
rather than I'll replicate
as I can.
To say I will replicate with
a good sense of what I'm
expecting to find.
Which brings me to the same
thing which is our saying it's
a very difficult ex-post not to
use the data to learn more
than what the hypothesis was at
the beginning because, you
know, it's sad.
So you could think about it in a
more constructive way, which
is you could think well, this is
what was my hypothesis was
in the beginning, this
is what I find.
In addition, I have also these
interesting, tantalizing
tidbits of results.
I'm putting it in front if you
admitting that it was not my
hypothesis to start with, but I
am contesting that it should
be the hypothesis of
the next study.
I'll give you one very
good example of that.
There was one project by David
McKenzie from the World Bank,
and Suresh de Mel, who works
in Sri Lanka, and Chris
Woodruff in UCSD, and they were
interested in the return
to capitol for very small
entrepreneurs.
So what they did is they gave
people in Sri Lanka a grant.
Small entrepreneurs, people who
had about $200 of working
capital, that's just
what we call a
helicopter drop of money.
So you get $100 grant
or $200 grant.
And they did that and they found
that at first you get
the average and they found
great returns to capital.
Very high returns to capital.
So very beneficial to give
people of the other
5% percent a month.
So very high return
to capital.
Great.
And then they decided to do it
separately at women and men.
And oh, surprise, they found no
return whatsoever for the
women, and huge return
for the men.
So you can say, sorry, it was
not in your original design.
It was not stratified by gender,
so we have really no
intents that you are--
so we have to
throw this result away.
Of course, we don't want to
throw this result away because
that's so surprising and
striking that we kind of want
to think about it.
So what's the idea?
You write this up being very
explicit that we found this
ex-post, but it seems
like really robust.
We are going to go and do a new
experiment, so we could
redo it in Sri Lanka or do
it in somewhere else.
And in this case, our hypothesis
is the age zero is
the return to capital are the
same for men and women, that's
what you are trying to reject.
So these scores are good
to think about.
These evaluations are part of
a process, we are not alone.
A lot of people are working
on this, there will be
replication either by
you or by others.
And being explicit up front
about what was your first
hypothesis and your
current model.
And was is it that you
found out as well?
Our goal is to not get mixed up,
and at the same time not
to lose the information
that is going to be
useful in the future.
So we stop at 12:00 whenever
we started, or what are the
social norms in this?
AUDIENCE: As long as you want.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I have a phone call at
12:30, otherwise--
AUDIENCE: It's 12:15.
PROFESSOR: I'd probably be
finished before that.
I don't have time to finish
what's on the slides anyway.
So I just wanted to give you
a sense of what might be a
causal model in this case.
The whole perception and goal is
not there, it's the public
goods thing.
And it's a way of disciplining
all of the outcomes, as well
as the various things
we spoke about.
So you start from reservation,
so one thing that reservations
definitely do is that
they will lead
to more women Pradhan.
And then the question is whether
or not having more
women Pradhan will change the
public good, and in what way?
And there are really two
channels to change the
preferences, which we
have discussed.
One is the women as the Pradhan
do what women want.
And you've not really discussed
that, but that comes
with its own set of assumptions
which is on the
one hand the Pradhan are not
representing the majority.
As always, the majority
hasn't changed.
We shouldn't see a difference
because even if you are
saying, well, you don't have to
be accountable to the men.
That's not true, because they
still do it for you.
Ex-ante.
Several woman compete, and the
issue is what platform are you
going to run on?
Well you should be running on
the platform that is going to
get you elected.
And whether or not you're a man
or a woman, you're elected
by the same group of people.
So in a totally stand out
model where democracy is
perfect, who is in charge
doesn't matter.
Because who is in charge is
representing the desire of the
majority, what we call
the median voter.
So if you had perfect democracy,
that channel would
be killed, and we wouldn't
see an impact.
On the other hand, if all the
decisions were made by a group
of elite villagers, that again
wouldn't matter because who is
in charge doesn't matter.
So the identity of the Pradhan
is going to make a difference
only in some
middle-of-the-road kind of [? ward ?]
where the politician has some
control over what is going on.
It is not completely controlled
by a bureaucracy or
by elite, and is not completely
accountable to the people.
But who is he?
He cannot fully commit, for
example, to a platform.
That doesn't seem unrealistic.
People make electoral promises
and sometimes
they go against them.
Almost never, but sometimes.
But that's something.
So if we do learn that the
public good prefers to change,
we have learned something
broader than just impact to
this program.
We have learned something about
politics in India, which
is OK, there is some
democracy.
Some people are contesting
that.
Some people say the Panchayat
is just a face.
There is no democracy really.
So if you find a difference by
the identity of the Pradhan,
it shows you by the by that
there is some reality in the
democratic system, but it's
not perfect democracy.
So if we've learned something,
it can be broader than a new
program as well.
And that is a lesson you
can take elsewhere.
Another channel by which a woman
having reservation can
influence the representation
of women is to more
representation.
For example, we were talking
about more political
participation of women if
the woman is the head.
So one thing that could be
true is that they're more
likely to show up in meetings,
that they're more
likely to speak up.
For example, because the women
have said that the Pradhan has
to be at the village meeting,
so she better put it at the
time where she can go.
So not in the middle of
the night in a field.
And so as long as she can
go, a woman can also go.
So to either of these channels,
you'd have the fact
that the public good will
reflect better women's
preferences.
We have to add another
assumption, is that women have
different preferences.
And if that's the case, then
the public good will be
different in a specific way,
which is towards those
different preferences.
And then you might have
different outcomes.
More income for the women,
better health and education
outcome, if it comes out that
it's what women care about.
And you'll be able to follow
exactly the trace that, you
know, if you find like in
West Bengal more water.
Maybe you're going to be
interested in diarrhea.
If you find less schools, you're
going to be interested
in education to see whether
education goes down, and
things like that.
So now we have the
complete channel.
And we can now think about all
of our variables that we had
collected, and we're going to
slot them into, well, what are
they going to do for us?
So all the public
goods go here.
We need to collect women's
preferences
somewhere, it will go here.
We want to know as a woman are
empowered, so we are going to
be collecting all of these.
Whether people come to the
meeting, whether they speak
up, how they are answered
to once they speak up.
This is all going to go here.
So now, if we have an infinite
amount of money we're still
going to collect a large amount
of data, but we know in
advance what it is we are
going to do with them.
We can write it down, put it
in an envelope, send it to
your grandmother, and this is
the thing that really gives a
lot of credibility to what
you're going to do.
Another version of sending it
to your grandmother that we
are going to try and implement
here at J-PAL is to allow you
to put it on a website, to
upload it somewhere where
nobody can see it but you,
but it's secure,
and the data is mapped.
So this is whatever it was your
analysis plan at the time
of the beginning
of your study.
So you are tying your hand
behind your back.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, but
why would you do that?
PROFESSOR: Because
we want to--
or maybe someone can answer
that question.
Why do we do that?
AUDIENCE: I guess it's just so
people aren't relying on your
personal integrity.
You're saying this was
our hypothesis.
We didn't ex-post change
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the reason why you want to
say what was your hypothesis
in advance, is because then
you can attest it.
Whereas if you take something
you can always reverse
engineer it.
And again, I have no big issue
with that, with reverse
engineering.
Personally, I think it's useful,
but it needs to be
very clear what was there before
and what was reverse
engineered after, otherwise
we have no notion
of statistical tests.
AUDIENCE: I'm just pushing out
a little bit further, too.
What if you just had a question
where you just don't
know, right?
You're like, wow, we really
think there might be an effect
of this on that, or we're not
sure whether the effect would
be upward or downward.
Do you still have to just pick
one for the sake of having a
hypothesis that you're
testing?
PROFESSOR: I think you wouldn't
want to embark in an
evaluation without at least
having a sense of why it would
go up and why it
would go down.
So take this specific example.
To start with, you shouldn't
really know whether the water
wells are going to go up and
down, because it's going to
depend on what women want.
So I'm not making a stance.
It would be silly to write
to my grandmother.
I'm betting that the women
water wells will go up.
Because they could go
up or down depending
on what women want.
Of course, you may have a very
strong prior that it's what
women want, but the statement
would be of the form, if it is
the case that women have a
strong preference for water,
water should go up.
So if you have some uncertainty,
it's probably
because there is an if somewhere
that you're not
thinking about that you're
expliciting now.
I think if thinking sufficiently
hard about
something, you can know
in what condition you
would go up and down.
There are a lot of programs
which could go up and down,
that's why we evaluate them.
I mean, sometimes you think that
they should really go up,
but it could also be zero.
And it's good to know, if this
and this happened then this
effect would be expected.
If this and this doesn't happen,
then I wouldn't see
this effect, so you
could write that.
And in fact, I think these
types of statements, in a
sense, are almost
more informative
than this will happen.
So let me stop here.
What's in the rest of
the slides is kind
of little bit random--
not randomized, but not random
in the sense of randomized,
but random in the sense of every
which way I pass out the
advice on how to collect data
and how to enter data and
things like that.
For those of you who are going
to IPA training after this,
you're going to be sick of it
by the end of the three days
so that's not needed.
For the other ones, it's in the
slides and it's really--
that's the problem of it
being too short anyway.
So it is pretty self-explanatory
and
relatively common sense and not
sufficient anyway, but a
starting point.
Thank you very much.